hi Barbie
hi Ken sequels to Barbie are more a
question of when rather than if there
are plenty of Barbies and Ken's to
follow into their own similarly
metadromedy vehicles that evolve from
the blueprint set out in the first film
too many talented young actors appear
here for one of them to not get another
shot as their respective doll identities
but with Mattel pledging to exploit all
the other toys in their massive IP toy
box there may be a larger Mattel
Cinematic Universe that Barbie would
merely be a player in how exactly could
Barbie team up with He-Man or the cars
from Hot Wheels or Rock'em sock'em
robots if you've already seen Barbie you
know that the doors are blown wide open
for any manner of tie-in to make some
kind of emotional sense even if it's
found to be wanting in the logic
Department Barbie could end up in
Eternia and the right combination of
winking nodding and sharply employed 80s
or 90s needle drops on the soundtrack
will smooth over any rockiness between
the various Brands respective identities